Welcome to Ear Biscuits, the
podcast where two life-long
friends talk about life for a long time.
Hey.
I'm Link.
And I'm Red.
This week, at a table that
is round, but there's not dim
lighting, it's a different table.
At our creative palace.
We're going to be having a
conversation that was spurred
by a question that was asked
during one of the AMA sessions
over on the Mythical Society.
We do that, I don't know
how often we do that.
Is it monthly?
Ah, is it every month?
Seems like it.
It seems like every month.
It's gotta be every month.
And Kimberley--
Society members ask us anything,
and then we answer them.
Yeah, yeah.
For a whole hour.
Whole hour.
We're both sitting around
laptops answering questions.
I didn't answer this question, by the way.
And I don't know the answer
to your question, so.
Well, I'm not gonna give you the answer.
I'll give you the question.
I was like, I was thinking
about this question last night,
and I was like, this will be
a good thing to hear Link's
answers, and also to analyze
my, what I'm gonna call
my knee-jerk answers.
So, the question was, if you
could witness any historical
event, what would it be?
Go back and witness any historical event.
And, again, when you're doing
an AMA, I mean, my philosophy
is, I want to answer as
many questions as possible.
You know, it's not that
I'm not being thoughtful,
but I'm not like.
You don't wanna over-think it--
I've really gotta think about this.
'Cause it's live and,
you know, they're waiting
for the answer to the question,
and you wanna get through
a bunch of them.
Right, and--
That's why I didn't even choose
that one, 'cause I'm like,
dang, that's a big question.
Well, a lot of times I
would avoid that question,
a question like that, like
this, because of what my answers
were, but that's why I
wanted to talk about it.
Just in the name of
vulnerability, self-exploration,
introspection, I thought
it would be interesting
to go back, I'll go through
my answers, which again,
I've actually thought
a little bit about them
and I was like, I probably wouldn't answer
this exactly the same
way, but I wanna explore
what my answers say about me.
And then I wanna hear
your answers, of course.
You've had a little bit, we
talked about it last night,
so you've had a little bit
more time to think about it.
Yeah, and I, you know,
when you first pitched
this as an Ear Biscuit, I
was, let's not do that one
because, like, I was
not in a frame of mind
to figure it out.
Like, it's a very intimidating question.
I mean, I don't know enough about history.
Like, all of a sudden, I feel exposed.
It's like, there should
be an obvious answer.
Now, I'll talk about my process
and a little bit about how
I arrived at my answers
when I give them to you.
To clarify, first of all,
you're not drinking beer
for those of you watching,
not that that would be,
that there's anything wrong with it,
but it's not apple juice either.
It's Kombucha.
But it's a Kombucha.
I gave three answers because
I couldn't narrow it down,
and I said my three answers
in chronological order are,
and so you've also given three answers.
Yeah.
Even though that wasn't
what Kimberley was asking,
she was just asking for one,
couldn't narrow it down to one.
So, that's what we're
gonna talk about today.
But before we talk about that.
What?
Let's talk about the fact that
we're both wearing shorts.
Oh, I see you looking at my,
are you looking at my legs or my shorts?
Well, I'm looking at your
shorts, but it's hard
not to see your legs because
your shorts are incredibly,
may I say, unnecessarily--
Nay, I say.
Dare I say, unnecessarily short.
Now, okay, I'm gonna stand
up and for those of you
watching, I'm gonna show you my shorts.
Go ahead and show them your shorts.
You look like a freaking, golf shorts?
Plaid shorts.
These are stylish, man.
Now, we don't, as a policy,
we don't wear shorts to work
or on video, but admittedly, I
have gone to an extreme here.
I mean, I'm gonna stand on
my tip-toes so you can see.
That's my leg there.
That's a lot of leg.
That's a lot more leg.
This is like a jogger's short.
Yeah, these are swim trunks,
'cause I've been working
on my tan line, and I like
my tan line to be very high.
Why don't I just do the
podcast standing like this?
Some people do that.
Just be standing.
Some people do it while walking.
You stay seated, and I'll stay standing.
But the reason why I'm
wearing shorts is not because,
you know, it's liable
to be in the mid-90s,
but I have got a break-out of poison ivy.
The temperature, you mean?
We're not going back in
time to the mid-'90s.
Yeah, it's really hot.
Dude, look at this thigh.
Look at my right thigh.
See my tan line there?
I mean, that's not a break-out,
that's like you've got
a touch of poison ivy.
Oh, you think that's--
You have a crescent of poison ivy.
I have a crescent of poison ivy.
I mean, I've been covered with poison ivy.
That's four inches.
You think that's four inches?
That explains a lot .
How long is that?
That is not four inches.
First of all, you're going past it.
That's three, actually no,
it's three inches if you.
Well, you're going too far on that side.
Well, I don't wanna touch it.
Well, then, three inches.
It's about four inches.
You have a three-inch
crescent of poison ivy.
This is not a life-altering situation.
I also have two dots right here on my hand
because it spreads via your blood stream.
And that's where I first noticed it.
I'm like, man, just below
my knuckle is itching.
What is that?
An itching zit?
I'm like, oh no, I remember this feeling.
We used to get it in
high school all the time
'cause we'd be constantly
getting poison ivy
because we'd be gallivanting in the woods.
And then, right here on this,
so that's my right knuckle,
my left shoulder, look at that.
One dot right there.
And that dot itches like mad.
And then I realized, you know what?
I've been scratching my
thigh under my britches.
I took my pants off two days ago.
Britches.
And there's this crescent,
four-inch crescent.
Three, three-inch.
At least.
If that, I'd say two point, 2.8 inches.
So, I've been applying rubbing alcohol
to it because that's what
the internet told me to do
to help dry it out.
I mean you can take--
No calamine?
No.
That doesn't happen anymore?
I'm just trying to dry it
out and give it some relief,
but at a certain stage, oh man,
I am reminded of when I had a whole lot.
Like, my whole leg will be eat up with it.
And my whole leg would turn
into like one solid welt.
Welp? What's the consonant
at the end of that word?
Welp? Welt?
I think it's a welt.
It welt up, man.
Even this much had me up
multiple times last night,
'cause I would wake up scratching it.
Well, because you're only
addressing the dryness of it,
you're not soothing it with anything.
That's what calamine does.
You've gotta soothe it.
Well, it does soothe it.
You can't just dry it.
It cools it off.
You're waking up scratching it,
it's obviously something's not working.
Well then, I've gotta go
put more alcohol on it.
You can't let a 2.8-inch
crescent of poison ivy
ruin your night's sleep.
I'd love for you to get it.
You know, I'm gonna take
some, whatever oozes off it,
and under this table
I'm gonna rub it on you.
That's not how it spreads.
Can't get it like that.
Well, you get it from
the oil in the plant.
The oil in the plant's gone, friend.
Now you're just having a reaction.
I can't get a reaction
from you having a reaction.
So, you're saying that the oil
that comes out of the thing--
That's not oil, that's pus.
Pus?
Yeah, you're not leaking poison oil.
Fine, I'm gonna rub my pus all over you,
if you won't shut up about it.
That would be very unpleasant,
but I would not get a crescent from it.
Just reminds me, after I go in the woods,
I took Lando in the woods, good gosh,
I'm so glad he didn't get it.
Did you wear
'Cause he'd be freaking out.
Shorts that short in the woods?
No, but I sat down for a while
and I think that's when it happened.
I don't know.
It could have entered my
blood stream somewhere else,
and then popped up there on
my leg 'cause I was scratching
my leg for another reason.
I don't know much about
poison ivy, but I don't think
you can get it on your leg
and have your blood stream
take it to your hand.
I think that it spreads within the section
through the blood stream, but not,
like, to another extremity.
I mean, any scientist,
any poison ivy scientists
We'll have to figure it out.
Hashtag EarBiscuits.
Let us know.
I just don't think it's possible.
I'll be good by then.
I think you got it on your
hand 'cause you touched it,
and I think you got it on
your leg 'cause you sat down.
We got it so bad in high school,
I had to go to the doctor
and get a cortisone shot,
no steroid shot, same thing.
Oh yeah.
So anyway, yeah, I'm wearing
shorts in order to air
out my pussy leg.
Oh God, I'm scared, careful.
Why are you wearing shorts?
'Cause we don't do that.
Well, I'm wearing shorts
because while we record
this podcast here, we don't
run the AC and it gets hots,
it gets very hot.
I mean, by the end of this
I'll be a shiny, sweaty mess
because we can't run the AC.
I mean, we should just
run the AC and let people
deal with the noise.
Go turn it on.
I brought a sweatshirt 'cause I knew
you were gonna insist on it.
That's crazy.
After last time.
But it's interesting that
even when we worked--
It's not crazy, it's being prepared.
When we worked in Lillington,
just the two of us,
in that basement, which
did have a window unit,
we wore jeans every single day.
Like, we made, we wore
flip-flops with our jeans,
and we wore t-shirts, but
we had this, like, idea
that you can't get work done in shorts.
What we really decided is, you know what?
We're not gonna wear shorts in videos.
My legs aren't gonna appear in videos.
You look like a hack.
I'm sure Mister Beast
could get away with it.
I'm sure he wears shorts in his videos.
I've never watched one, tell me.
Are you calling Mister Beast a hack?
No, I'm just saying he
can get away with it
because he has a different aesthetic.
It's just, like, a dude with
really, really good ideas,
the best ideas, the best
ideas on the internet maybe,
in terms of performance.
You can't argue with the numbers.
Am I a little bitter?
I've never watched his
videos, how could I be bitter?
Or jealous?
But, I mean, I could
see him wearing shorts.
I think he does.
I know he has a big
straw hat that he wears.
We try too hard to wear
shorts, because that undermines
the whole thing, but maybe that's it.
Maybe that's what we're discovering.
If we would just start wearing
shorts, why not wear shorts?
I mean, Shia Labeouf wore
shorts on "Hot Ones".
Yeah, he did.
And he didn't care.
Well, I've been thinking
seriously about wearing shorts
to the office because of this.
This is our problem.
To the actual office.
You know, we're talking about--
But I don't wanna set the wrong tone.
People are liking "Good Mythical More."
Some people are saying they
like "Good Mythical More"
more than they like
"Good Mythical Morning",
the show before it, the actual show.
And we're starting to figure
out, oh they're picking up
on something, right?
The shorts.
It's that we change into shorts mentally.
Mentally, we change into shorts
for "Good Mythical More".
This is just for anybody.
It's more unbuttoned.
If you wanna be here, you can be here,
but we're not gonna beg you to be here,
and we're not gonna care what you think
about us if you are here.
We're in this together.
Right.
I think that's the key
to "Good Mythical More"
is that we put on our mental shorts.
And you know what?
This is gonna be a good podcast
'cause we've got physical
shorts on, but my thigh's
kind of pussy and itchy.
But your particular shorts,
if we're going to wear
shorts to the office, or begin
wearing shorts more often,
I don't think you can
wear that kind of short.
I'm a little bit, I'm approaching--
Mine are dressier.
Yeah.
And longer.
And embarrassing.
That's a seven-and-a-half-inch difference.
By the way, this is
seven-and-a-half-inches.
I'm pointing to my inseam.
That's what
seven-and-a-half-inches looks like.
I mean, are you going golfing later?
Actually I might later, yeah.
Okay, well then, you're ready.
But see--
I'm ready to go swimming.
Plaid shorts look good
on anyone at any time.
The only reason I'm wearing these shorts,
the shortest shorts I've got,
is because the other shorts
they go half way on the
crescent, and they chafe it.
Okay.
They chafe my crescent.
Roll them up.
The thing about plaid shorts
is you can be ready for anything.
You can be ready to have
a mai thai poolside,
but you can also have
a business transaction.
You could not do business in those shorts.
You could only run from business.
Or run to a business
meeting and then change
into a legitimate outfit.
I don't like how we look
in shorts on camera,
in a full body shot.
I'm starting to like the
way I look in shorts.
Well, I'm not.
Okay.
These'll be the shorts that I wear
if that's where we're going.
Let's, okay then, I'll put
on three pairs of pants
if that's what it takes.
Okay, we're gonna talk about
these historical events
that we would like to witness.
But first, we're gonna talk
about how you should groom
yourself like a chimpanzee,
and you can do that with our
help because we've got
palm-aid, we've got beard oil,
we've got lip balm.
I mean, your whole, at
least from the neck up,
we can make you look like a million bucks.
I think we still have some cologne too.
It may be gone away, so
if you wanna collect that,
it may be too late.
If there's some left,
it is the last of it.
That's for sure.
And I hate that because
I really love the scent.
Grooming products galore,
mythical.com smell like us.
Yeah.
But you know, style like yourself.
You know, express yourself on
your head and on your lips.
Okay--
And in your heart.
And on your thighs.
Okay, so you answered this question.
I mean, you somehow came
up with three answers
to if you could travel back in time
and witness any event in history.
Now, there's no exact
timeline, but there's a couple
of ground rules here that were implied,
that at least, I assumed.
One is you can't change history,
you can't have any impact on it, right?
That was implied.
I also assumed that--
I'm probably gonna disagree
with this, I can tell
by the look in your eye.
That it couldn't kill you.
Like, I mean, if someone
said I'm gonna go back to,
I wanna see a specific volcano
erupting, like there's one
huge eruption that a lot
of people say they wish
they could go back and see,
but it'd probably kill you.
So I'm assuming that you would be safe.
I disagree with that.
So okay, your assumption was
that you wouldn't stay safe.
Oh no, no, I thought you were
saying you could be killed.
When I give you my first
answer you'll understand that--
You're in a hypothetical but,
what's the word, bubble of safety.
So, I assume that as well.
And in terms of how much time,
there's a little flex here,
but it really can't be
more than, like, 24-hours.
I mean, if it's a, if you
wanted to go see a concert,
maybe you could do that, but I don't know
that you could go to,
like, a week-long festival.
The funny thing about
all three of my answers
is I'd probably need about a minute.
Oh really?
Yeah.
A minute.
Right.
'Cause I was thinking, okay,
it seems like we're thinking differently.
Well, okay, so and this was knee-jerk,
but these were the
assumptions you brought to it,
but then you were like,
all I need is a minute?
Well, 'cause I'm going
back, well, let me explain.
Give me one.
And I'm going in chronological order.
And so the first one was--
The big bang.
The moment just before the big bang.
Okay, I was right.
Which again, the moment before
the big bang is, I guess,
theoretically unwitnessable
because there was nothing to...
But that's the thing, was
there nothing to witness?
And I'm also assuming
that if there is some God
who instituted the big
bang, I would be able to see
this God do the work, right?
So, once again, it's not something--
First thing I'd be looking
at is is God wearing shorts?
Did God just light the
fuse to the big bang?
That would be my second thing.
Is God in shorts?
And is there some sort of lighter?
Is it one of those BIC
lighters, those are frustrating.
No, no, I assume God has
one of the long lighters.
You gotta push and pull the trigger.
Like, he's got the one
I light my grill with.
Right when you get one of those things,
you crank it up all the way.
Or is this just me?
Every time I get a new one of
those longy trigger lighter
things, you know where it's got that knob,
it's like the negative-positive slider.
Go all the way, yeah.
I hit that thing all the way to positive
and and I'm like,
wow, it's like a torch.
I think God has a butane lighter.
And then after that--
Like for cigars.
Even like--
'Cause he would definitely smoke cigars.
The next time I use...
Well, don't call God a he.
Maybe they, maybe God, I'll just say God,
maybe God lit the big bang with a cigar
they were already smoking.
That's not--
When you start a fire with a
thing that's in your mouth,
that you're already smoking,
that's about as badass
as you can be.
Like, in a movie when you've
covered somebody in gasoline
and like, lit a trail to them.
Right, right, right,
God need not be badass.
He has nothing to prove to you.
He?
Oh.
Yeah, you did it.
Yeah, it's hard not to.
Just tradition.
Okay, but I thought--
But then after a couple of
uses, even though that thing's
on the plus, the flame is so small.
Yeah, well, let's get back to
the nature of the question,
and not God's lighter.
That's fair.
So, again, obviously--
You wanna know how it started.
Well, yeah.
I mean, you'll see all my
questions relate to these kinds
of issues, that was where
my mind was at at the time
when I answered this question.
It wasn't like, what
would be cool to witness?
And what would be fun to witness?
It was, what would unravel
the deepest mysteries
of the universe, if I had the
ability to go do that, right?
Knowledge.
So, in this one in particular,
this question in particular, you know,
when we shared our deconstruction stories.
For those of you who don't
know, a few months ago
we did a series called "The
Lost Years" where we talked
about our history growing
up and becoming adults,
working in Christian ministry,
evangelical Christians,
and now we're no longer, we
no longer identify as that.
I identify as what I
call a hopeful agnostic.
And it's interesting, people,
lots of people, on both sides,
were like, well, you really
can't just be an agnostic,
you're either an agnostic
theist or an agnostic atheist.
And I'm like, okay, that
may be your opinion,
but I'm not gonna label
myself with what you want me
to label myself.
Because the thing that I am agnostic
about is whether or not God exists,
so I'm not gonna be an agnostic theist,
or an agnostic atheist,
because that represents
a disposition in one
direction or the other.
Or, to me, it represents, like, you know,
the agnostic atheist would be like,
I definitively am saying
that, I'm not even gonna try
and put words in your mouth,
the people who told me
that I needed to identify
as one or the other.
I'm just saying I don't identify as,
I just identify as an agnostic.
But, I have a, like I say,
I'm a hopeful agnostic, right?
So you don't know, but you hope to know.
And I'm not saying that
I hope, necessarily,
there is a God in the
traditional sense of, like,
the Christian God, you
know, a personal God
that has this very specific
interest in everybody's life,
and is sitting in judgment
or sitting in love, or both,
or righteousness, or
whatever your description
of God would be.
But, I just have this thing
that I can't let go of,
which is it can't, it could
be, but there's a part
of my brain that's just like,
it just can't be just the universe, right?
Could it really just be the universe?
I mean, I guess, theoretically,
practically, scientifically,
yes it could just be, because
you get back to the argument
where you're like, well God created it.
And you're like, well, who created God?
So then God, kind of, becomes
your de facto universe
that has always existed.
But that's where the big
bang raises this question
because it's basically saying
there was a beginning, right?
And there was potentially
nothing before it,
or maybe there was, it exploded
out of another universe.
Or maybe it was another universe
that collapsed on itself
and then exploded again.
And I feel like if I could
go back right before it--
It would be all of existence breathing,
and it would be the beginning,
the end of an in-breath
and a beginning of another out-breath.
But most of the current
data suggests that,
they thought for a long time
that maybe after millions,
billions of years of
expansion, that our universe
would then begin to
collapse back on itself,
but it's actually speeding
up, and it seems like
we're just gonna, sort of--
Dissipate?
Slowly, everything would just homogenize
throughout the universe, so
there's really no falling
back together and blowing up again.
Who knows?
I mean, that's what things,
that's what it seems like right now
but they could make a new
discovery to change that.
Yeah, so if you go right
before the big bang,
would you be seeing stuff, I
mean you wouldn't see anything.
Even if things were coming back together.
I mean, you said, you'd
only need a minute for this?
Like, the moment before
the big bang, what?
I don't think you would learn anything.
No, I would either see a
bunch of shit collapsing
on itself right before it
comes down to that moment.
Or I would see nothing, and
you can't, I mean literally,
if nothing exists, I
couldn't see anything.
Like, where would I be placed?
It doesn't exist.
Maybe I would just destroy
myself by trying to see this.
But again, we're--
You're in a hypothetical safety bubble.
I'm in a bubble.
Or maybe, if I was to enter
into some sort of, like,
spiritual state in which it was, oh,
this is what you might call God existing
on their own without
any separate creation.
And I'm assuming that in
my hypothetical bubble,
I would be able to witness that as well.
That's a risky one though.
I mean, it would, it
could really screw you up
psychologically, I don't think the bubble
could help with that.
I don't think it could
protect you psychologically.
And honestly, I don't know
what would change in my life
depending on the answer,
because as I may have not said this, but--
Well, based on this answer, okay.
I think I know where you're
going with another one.
'Cause it's not that I
don't believe in God.
I don't know.
And if it turns, if I went
back and I saw, oh no,
this is purposeful, ultimately purposeful,
and there's an intelligent
being behind it,
it's not like I would
back-track on everything
and be like, oh I've gotta
go be a Christian again.
Because the reasons I'm not
a Christian are not based
on a rejection of the Kalam
cosmological argument,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay, right.
The reason I'm not a Christian
is because I don't believe
the tenets of Christianity
and the historical basis
of Christianity as reliable.
And maybe we'll get back to that one.
All right, so are we going to?
Let's go back and forth, yeah.
I think we're gonna pick
up with this conversation,
right here, where we're gonna
leave it off for a second
because I mean, like I said,
this is kind of an intimidating
question for me.
I couldn't rattle off three
things off the top of my head.
I guess, because I was also thinking,
what would be a cool thing to witness?
And then I said, and learn something?
But also be fun to talk about.
Honestly, that became another criteria.
And the first thing that came to my mind
was how did the Egyptians
freaking build the pyramids?
That's a good one.
I mean, the huge freaking pyramid.
I mean, they haven't figured it out.
Aliens.
You got like, 80-ton granite blocks--
Awolens, as Lachie used
to say when he was a kid.
A-what?
Awolens.
Awolens, it was awolens, Dad.
80-ton granite stones,
they had to move 500-miles.
So then I'm trying to figure out,
if I'm gonna only be there for a day,
I could definitely
witness how they did it,
some people say slave
labor, some people say
that it's skilled labor,
there's hundreds of people,
there's thousands of people.
They estimate that it took
a couple of hundred years
to build the pyramids.
Really?
Yes.
A couple of hundred years?
Okay, then it probably wasn't awolens.
Right.
It was probably just people.
'Cause they don't have
that type of patience.
I think aliens would have
done it a lot faster.
But look that up, verify it.
How long it'd take to build the pyramids.
You know how I am with numbers.
That's a good point.
So I had to try and figure
out, okay, if I go back,
I could kind of solve this mystery.
You know, I could say, well
this is how they did it.
I'm into systems, you know,
into production systems
as an industrial engineer by degree.
So, I thought that would be cool.
I thought I could come back
and it'd be cool to say,
"Well, when I was there,
"I couldn't understand
what they were saying."
You know it's like, I also assume
that the language barrier is intact.
Which, that surprises
me, that's a problem.
100 years.
Edgar Case reported that it took 100 years
to build the Great Pyramid.
Most of the blocks were limestone
quarried at Giza or nearby.
It's still a long time but
that's not an alien timeline.
Aliens would be like .
I think they're saying
A weekend.
The limestone rocks are from nearby,
but they were just the
outer part of the pyramid.
That now, the vast
majority of that is gone.
'Cause you know, I was
trying to figure out--
'Cause it was smooth at one point.
Yeah, do I wanna see the
pyramid, like, on the day
of its completion, like,
whatever coronation
or the ribbon-cutting ceremony.
First of all, I would just like to see
the pyramids, in general.
But there's a lot of smog, and I think--
Smog is a problem?
Smog is a problem, and there's a lot
of pollution there on the--
Because Lach and I were thinking about,
Egypt was one of the
potential places on our list.
You can't, you don't wanna go
when it's exasperatingly hot
because I know how you look in shorts .
Can you wear shorts over there?
Certain countries you just can't,
you shouldn't be wearing shorts.
I believe you can, as a
dumb tourist or something.
But they put limestone,
smooth limestone pieces
that they cut and made the
whole outside of it smooth
and white, and this thing, I
would have loved to have seen
it during the ribbon-cutting
because it would have been
a shimmering 450-foot tall pyramid.
It would be awesome, but it's not as--
In the middle of the desert.
And I could probably still
find out how they did it.
No, you can't, not at the
coronation, unless the aliens
are still there and they cut the ribbon
and get in their saucer and go away.
I think I would go for one
day while they were building
it, like, at the two-thirds point.
At some point while they're
still hauling big rocks,
because I can't talk to them.
I can talk to them but they
wouldn't understand me.
Right.
But I think that's what I would do.
I like where you're heading with this.
Kind of an obvious answer.
But I feel like, most
likely, I'd say 99.7% chance,
that if you went back in the
middle of the building process,
it would be like, oh okay,
this engineering technique.
That's impressive.
Pulleys, levers, log-roads, whatever.
You know, it'd be some of the
theories that exist already.
But is gonna be like--
There's a new theory, that
they turned the desert
into, like, mud roads.
Yeah, it's something--
I would be into that.
But it'd be pretty cool.
I'd be into that.
You could come back and you
could be on one of those shows
on SciFi and you could be
like, "Listen, I know this guy
"with the big hair thinks
that aliens did it, but I,
"the man in the short
shorts, I took a bubble back
"to the time and I can
tell you definitively."
People probably wouldn't
believe you though.
I mean, when I looked at the
ancient temples in Thailand
when I toured them, and
walked around them, and walked
right up to a lot of them,
I mean, they're like,
not nearly as tall as the
Great Pyramid or anything,
but it was really cool to.
That's the first time I've ever
been around ruins, you know?
Which I've talked about
on this podcast before.
But it was cool to just imagine
what it was like in its hay-day.
In its hay-day, yeah.
Ribbon cutting.
But you could, kind
of, go to other temples
around Thailand and then see that too.
So, I didn't really feel like I needed
to travel back in time.
You can be like, this
is what it looks like,
this is what it probably looked like.
Yeah, but that would be cool.
Okay, so since we've
got four more to cover
between the two of us.
Yeah, what's your next one?
My next one was the moment of abiogenesis.
So, the moment that the first
life-form came to be, right?
That has to look boring.
Like, what are you, you're talking about--
Listen, again, I'm telling
you my knee-jerk responses.
Would you take a microscope?
Now that I've thought about
it more, it's like, yeah,
I couldn't witness it.
I wouldn't know what was going on.
Well, probably something
with some amino acids
coming together to form
a more complex structure.
Yeah, it's not really
visible to the naked eye.
But, here's the thing.
Just change it to dinosaurs.
Just say dinosaurs.
I'm not changing it 'cause
you've gotta roll with me here
and understand what I'm going for.
Because again, I would have
one minute, all I need's
a minute, to tell you whether
one of two or three things
is happening, right?
So, if you go back to this
moment, you know, many people
would say, well, that
moment doesn't exist, right?
There was never a moment
in which life sprung
from inorganic materials, right?
Because God did it, right?
According to the Bible or
whatever your religious text
of choice would be, right?
So that there's not a moment,
or if it was a moment,
it's something that you
would be able to ascertain
whether or not it was supernatural.
So, if you just asked to go
back, if you rubbed the lamp
and it was like, okay, I'm gonna
send you back to the moment
of, what did you call it?
Abiogenesis?
Abiogenesis, yeah.
It's be like, all of a
sudden, there would be like,
Adam would show up, like, "Hey man."
Right, but, so I think
there's a very, very small
chance that anything like
that happened, right?
So that's not why I'm going back.
And I actually think
that if there is a God
who has a purpose for the universe,
it would be very difficult
to ascertain the purpose
in any other moment in
history of the world,
other than right before
the big bang, right?
To me, that's a more definitive point
because even if life sprung
from inorganic material
at some point of the distant past,
and then it slowly has evolved
into what we have today,
that's an amazing thing
and that may require a God,
but it isn't like, it's the kind of thing
you look at and there's
a qualitative conclusion
which you come to which is I believe
that there has to be a
God for this process.
It isn't like I saw a big finger
come in and touch the water.
You know what I'm saying?
In other words, I don't
think you would ascertain
a supernatural moment.
So, that's not really what I'm going for.
But it's whether or not it did
happen, or if it was awolens.
And I'm serious about this one.
Because I think that it's a legitimate--
First of all, can I just say
as a tangent that, I mean,
we know that there's, when I
talk about the Adam and Eve
of it all, we know that
there's Christians who think
that if you went back in
time you would go back
to a microscopic amino
acid level, you know, point
in the evolutionary process
that then there are many
that believe that,
like, the first human...
That was part of it, and
they would go back there too.
That's what I'm saying.
But there's still an
Adam that could be like,
some divine injection of
a consciousness or soul.
No, that was my point.
My point was if I went
back to that moment, again,
like you said, many Christians
believe in the scientific
timeline of how things
happened, they just think God
is responsible for it.
Right.
And even if you're able to
figure out how to synthesize
amino acids into some more
complex life-form in a lab,
all you're doing is proving
that it takes some sort
of intelligent input in
order to happen, right,
and that's what God was responsible for.
I get that.
So back to what you're
saying, if you went back
to see if there was an alien
deposit made on this planet.
Right, because there's some
really interesting things.
You've got the Cambrian Explosion, right,
where all of a sudden,
in the fossil record
there's all these complex
organisms that seem to, kind of,
come out of nowhere on a geological scale.
And so, my best guess is there's
still a natural explanation
for all this stuff, but--
Then you should look at
the Cambrian Explosion
on my right thigh.
But what if the very
first thing that happened
was like a alien coming
in with a little thing
and it's like, here's--
A syringe .
Let's syringe this planet.
Why are you motioning a
syringe from a nipple?
All aliens extract life
juice from their nipples.
It makes that noise.
Sadly, I don't think you'd
see anything, because--
Well, probably not, I'd be able to--
An alien who's that
advanced, even if the alien
it would be some sort of,
you probably wouldn't see anything.
They're not gonna waste
their time and energy
to physically show up and doink doink.
No, but I'm saying that,
in my hypothetical bubble,
I would be able to be present.
Even if they, I'm not saying
they showed up and squeezed
it out of their literal nipple,
but maybe they had, like,
some sort of cosmic, you
know, quantum-powered needle
that flew through the universe
and then tracked itself
onto habitable planets and
planted the seeds of life.
What if that's what happened?
What if that ends up being
the explanation for why
there's life on earth and
elsewhere potentially?
Because some other species--
I just think they would be so advanced
that you wouldn't be able to
witness anything meaningful.
To you.
But anything out of the ordinary.
Yeah.
Anything mechanical.
I'm saying I think I would
be able to see something.
I think I'm influenced by
the three body problem.
They start talking about
how different beings operate
on so many different
dimensions, like, fourth, fifth,
tenth dimension, that we
can't even interact in.
We haven't talked about this.
We're gonna not only
do a podcast about it,
but we've talked about how
we're actually going to try
to do it, but there are people,
there's a large movement
out there, and because the
theory is aliens are operating
on a different plane of
existence, what we might call
a spiritual plane, you can
actually, sort of like,
what was the name?
Coast to coast, what was that radio show?
Coast to Coast, yeah.
Who was the host of Coast to Coast?
Jim?
Bohannon?
Maybe, I don't know.
What a great show.
But there's a lot of
people, and not just people
that you would just
traditionally call a quack,
but people that seem to be--
Now that you think you might
be one, they're not a quack.
No, but I like to allow myself to believe
the possibility and we
actually have some pretty good
friends that we trust,
who have had experiences
that are difficult to explain.
I prefer the phrase
entertain the possibility,
because I think that is part of my motive,
is that even if it's not
true, it's fun to engage in,
and until it gets scary.
Right, so anyway, that is
something for the future
that we may be legitimately trying
to make contact with aliens.
Okay, so my second one.
I have to believe this is your third one.
Oh, okay.
I mean, the whole Jesus of it all.
You're going back in time, I
mean, if you grew up in a way
different than us, you might say Buddha.
Right.
But probably not, and I'll explain why
when I get to my answer.
I had to say Jesus because
I have so many questions
that I hung my life on, and
then like, I've taken my
coat rack off of the Jesus rod.
Oh my God.
Oh gosh, I didn't mean that.
You should have thought about that analogy
a little bit more.
What's it called?
The thing you hang your clothes on?
A curtain rod, I mean
rod is the correct word.
It's not a curtain rod, it's a closet rod.
Right, yeah.
Now, I'm like, my clothes
are just all floating.
So, I'm trying to figure
out, okay, is that,
am I gonna go back to
the, again, I'm thinking,
it's gotta be less than
24-hours so I can't go back to,
like, the execution of Jesus
and then wait for three days,
and hang out at the right
spot to see if he comes,
if he raises from the dead.
I don't know why you're
getting hung up on the timeline
because yes, this is
my third, I just said,
the resurrection or
non-resurrection of Jesus.
So, the resurrection--
I'm assuming that the
person in charge of granting
this wish, who ironically
is probably God--
Could plop you down in the right spot.
Puts us in the right spot.
In the tomb.
Inside of the tomb.
Maybe outside of the tomb.
You probably don't wanna be in it.
I ended up landing on,
you know, when Jesus
started appearing to people.
When Jesus appeared to--
But you wouldn't know
what he looked like, so--
When Jesus appeared to the
disciples in the upper room,
yeah, I wouldn't know
what he looked like, but.
Even in the Bible, it
talks about the first time
that they saw him, they
didn't even recognize him.
Yeah, that's interesting.
Which was always interesting to me.
Well, I thought about that.
So you're shooting that
down, and then I'm like--
Why not the moment--
Okay, what about just a miracle.
Like, witnessing the--
That's what I'm talking about.
Well not the resurrection
because I think that's hard to witness.
You mean like feeding the 5,000?
Yeah, feeding, he's breaking--
Walking on water.
He's breaking up some loaves and fishes.
Water to wine.
Water to wine?
Bringing somebody back from the dead.
Restoring their eyesight.
Yeah, I think it's gotta be
raising Lazarus from the dead.
It's gotta be that one.
I think that feeding the--
That was pretty--
I think that feeding the 5,000
is one that you could not,
like, Lazarus could have
been, it could have been like,
this guy hasn't been dead
for as long as they realized,
or they thought, maybe
he was just really sick.
You know what I'm saying?
There's other ways to
squirrel out of that one.
But the feeding the 5,000
is like, all right, we got--
You don't have to know--
We got a couple of fishes and loaves.
You don't know the medical
condition of someone,
was he really blind before Jesus
made the mud pie in his eye?
Yeah I was thinking about
that one too because, like,
I saw this kid bring
this bread and these fish
and I was right there, and then it just
just kept coming.
And the reason I'm
choosing the resurrection,
because first of all, I
mean, my best guess, again,
I'm in the upper-90% on
this, not to be dismissive
of many millions of people,
billions of people believe
that these things happen.
I don't.
So, my best guess is that
story, the feeding of the 5,000,
you would go back and either
A, it never happened at all.
Like, it's completely made up.
Or, B, it's based on, like,
this one time that, you know,
they made a lot of food go really far
and it was pretty impressive,
and it got turned into
the story that it is.
Whatever, right?
But the resurrection--
But if you went back to that
time and then it was a flop,
or nothing happened, it'd be
like, okay, it didn't happen.
Okay, so that's what I wanted
to get at because, again--
And this is not enough to
rule out every other thing,
but it would--
Well, that's why I'd go
back to the resurrection
because it is the crux of it all.
Sure it is, it's just hard to know.
It's not hard to know.
If you're in the tomb, yes, and he's dead
and then all of a sudden he sits up.
And it's not like he comes
out, like, all beat up.
The dude comes out with a new body.
And there's an angel there.
Yeah, this is definitive stuff.
Okay, yeah.
And also it is the crux of it all.
Just like Paul said, you
know, if Christ didn't rise
from the dead, then this is all in vain.
Like, we should be
pitied above all people.
I'll go with that then.
And so--
That's a pretty big deal.
But, for me--
This should have been our first answer.
Well, I was going--
Chronologically.
Chronological, but I was also, kind of,
going to the biggest question,
which is is there purpose behind all this?
And, like I said, I tend to believe that,
I tend to want to believe that there is.
And then there's the
second question is like,
is there some point of
intervention in the origin of life?
And then this, is really
zeroing in on something
that is just very personal to us, right?
The philosophy that we
hung our clothes on,
whatever your analogy was,
for the majority of our lives,
and based a lot of our
early life decisions on,
is predicated on the idea
that this actually happened, right?
That Jesus did raise from
the dead and, kind of,
everything flows from that.
And then you're able to take other things,
like feeding the 5,000, and be like, well,
if he rose from the dead,
sure he could do this, right?
But, I was interested in
the fact that that was one
of my answers, right?
Because I think, again, it
was a knee-jerk response,
but I'm like, why do you want
to go back to that moment?
'Cause you don't know.
No, but I feel like I don't
know, but I feel like,
again, what are the--
If you someone raised from
the dead, you'd be blown away.
You'd be like, that would be a surprise.
That's not what you're expecting to see.
Not even close to what
I'm expecting to see.
What I'm expecting to see is either,
I believe that the information
we have about the post,
the life of Jesus, and especially like,
the post-death events, is
like, I think is legend, right?
You know, I think that,
I'm not one of these people
that are saying, well, this
is my, I have subscribed
to one of these, like the swoon theory,
or one of these other ideas
that he wasn't really dead,
and then he fooled
people into coming back.
I would just be like, he just was a dude
that was a revolutionary,
that everybody loved,
and he got killed, and then
because people wanted to keep
his memory alive, they...
There's some, humans can freaking invent
all kinds of stuff, right?
I mean, look at what's happening
in our country right now.
There's a bunch of people
who won't wear a damn mask.
It's like, and they'll die over this.
So it's like, it doesn't take much--
Yeah, I think what you're
saying is people die
for all types of beliefs.
Right.
And also, the whole idea that
the disciplines died for a lie
is, and that's proof,
and that's super-suspect,
and we actually don't
know that's the case,
'cause we don't actually know
definitively, historically,
the circumstances of their deaths.
So anyway, but--
I would really like to know though.
It'd be better than talking
about it like we are right now.
Right.
Hey, I was there.
Right, but I think for
me, it would be like--
The thing is there were people
who say they were there,
and then, you know, it's--
Right, right, but I guess
what I'm saying is--
But it's not definitive.
It's frustrating.
For me, it would be
there's just like, okay,
and I'm not saying that,
legitimately, I do not sit up
at night, I don't think about
this on a regular basis,
but it was when that question
was asked, it was like,
you know, let's scratch that off the list,
because not just for me
personally, but again,
it's not like I'd come back and say,
"Hey guys, it didn't happen,
"I went into the bubble
and it didn't happen."
All these people would be like,
"We're not Christians anymore."
Like, it doesn't work that way.
But it was this thing like,
okay, that must still mean
more to me than I even realize, right?
The need to want to confirm
the decision that I've made,
to come to the conclusion
that it didn't happen.
Yeah, definitely.
I think a part of this
is also, I don't know if,
did you end up reading
"The Universal Christ" by Richard Rohr?
No, not yet, at least.
So, Richard Rohr, who's a Franciscan Monk,
who's written a bunch of incredible books,
from a very different
perspective on Christianity
than the one we, kind of, came up with.
And it's definitely a
much more palatable form
of Christianity for me personally.
But, I really like the way
he thinks about the idea
of what Jesus is, and
what Jesus represents,
and what the Christian life is all about.
I mean, so much so that I'm
like, I could get into that.
Like, when I read his
work, that's how I think
'cause it's just like,
it's a way to, kind of,
capture the hope that I have,
and also apply it to the tradition
that I still know relatively well,
but not in a dogmatic way
where it's just like...
Christianity, for me, most of my life,
was a set of principles,
basically a set of statements
that you had to agree with, right?
And he's like, that's not what it is.
It's basically a way of being.
Which is an attractive thing.
But he talks, he believes
in the resurrection.
He actually talks about it
in "The Universal Christ"
and talks about the
moment of resurrection,
he anticipates it would
be like you would see
light pouring out of the tomb.
I haven't read it recently,
so I'm not getting this right.
But the idea that it was
like a dude walking out
and talking to people,
and I'm not sure exactly
what he believes, but
he's basically saying
that this is like a cosmic
event that represents something
much bigger than traditionally
we've given it credit for.
So I think that it was, kind
of, on my mind a little bit.
It's like, okay, if I go back
and see what I'm expecting,
which is, you know, some
natural explanation,
body stolen, it wasn't even as eventful.
Maybe his body was consumed by animals,
which often happened to
people who were crucified.
Lots of different explanations.
But if I went back and I saw
the light, or I saw him emerge.
Or even just an angel.
If it's like, hey you just missed it,
like everybody else, by the way.
Yeah.
I'm sure it can be seen
as a beautiful thing,
but to me, it's a frustrating thing.
It's like, something so
momentous, no one saw it.
I mean, Jesus appeared
to people afterward.
According to Paul, up to 500 at one time.
But it was a small movement, man.
And it wasn't, you know?
It's frustrating.
Well, again, I think knowing--
I don't want to--
But knowing what we know
about the way people work,
and the way people
begin to believe things,
and the people's disposition
to believe things,
it is not unbelievable to
me at all that there could
have been absolutely
nothing that happened,
and still the movement would have started.
I know people say that you
can't explain the beginning
of Christianity without the resurrection,
I just disagree with that.
But, I think that if I saw it--
Because look at the other
movements that started.
Look at all types of
movements, big and small.
But I think that the idea...
Because I think the question
is if I were to see something,
if I were to see something
that was not what I was expecting,
but it was the resurrection in some form,
like, what would that do to me, right?
Would I all of a sudden be like, okay,
I take back everything I said?
I take back all the issues
that I have with the historical claims.
that I have about the scientific stuff.
Archeological stuff.
No, I don't think that I
would, but I would be like,
oh, okay, there is something
here that's very significant
and might be the reason
that we're all here.
And it's got something to do with Jesus.
And again, there are
plenty, I think Richard Rohr
is an example of it, there
are plenty of Christians
who don't get hung up on those things
that I would have had an issue
with and were the reasons
that I left, who kind of
hold to just the core tenet
that Jesus represents this,
you know, restoration of God,
you know, reconciliation
of God and people,
that broken relationship being healed.
But I kind of, there's
a part of me that is,
I don't dispute that anyway.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Like, that's cool, I'm okay with that.
I may not be personally
practicing it or experiencing it,
but I don't have a problem with that idea.
I don't have a problem
with any of the stuff
that Richard Rohr said in
his book, in other words.
I would like to think that
I am open, in the same way
that if I went back, if
I could do this exercise,
that I would be open to whatever
on the other side of that time
warp that I would witness.
I would try to be as open as possible.
I try to be as open as possible now.
Well, I mean, our best
friend, Mike McHargue,
wrote a book about this,
in a lot of ways, right?
Mm-hmm, yeah.
So, he was an evangelical
Christian, he became an atheist
because of, kind of, studying,
reading a lot, and then--
It's called "Finding God in the Waves"
if you're interested.
And then he had this supernatural
experience with Jesus,
and so, he would still
call himself a Christian,
but does he hold to the
evangelical tenets of the,
not even close, but he holds to the idea
that there's a loving God with
a purpose in this world and--
Jesus doesn't make you an evangelical.
Yeah, and Jesus is a central
part of that for him.
And again, he's way smarter than I am,
and he's a close friend,
and I'm not gonna dispute his experience.
But for me--
But it was a mystical encounter.
So, I feel like if I had,
and I continue to be open
to that kind of encounter,
I mean, just a second ago
I was talking about potentially
connecting with aliens,
so I'm open to quite a bit.
But I think it would just,
it would give me a little bit
of motivation to move in
a particular direction
from a spiritual standpoint.
That's what it would do.
I've got one more .
'Cause, I mean, we could
talk about this all day.
Right.
But to complete my
exercise, I was like, man,
I've gotta swing the
pendulum a little bit.
I mean, what would just be fun?
Like, I'd like to have
one that was just like,
I mean, what would I enjoy
the most going back to?
And, I was like, it probably
has something to do with music.
That would be cool to witness--
The first music.
The first caveman to go like, .
What is happening?
I think I'm singing.
Do you think the first song
came before the first word?
Was it like ?
Yeah, that was it.
What does "Smoke on the
Water" have at the start?
.
Do you think "Smoke on the
Water" was made by a caveman
who couldn't speak?
I believe, it sounds, it's
the most caveman-like riff.
I don't think, that's not
my answer, is what I'm.
It's not, I quickly moved on
from any of those thoughts,
into, I mean, it'd be
cool to go to Woodstock
or like, The Last Waltz,
The Band's last concert.
I mean, then I'm like, I'm
not much of a concert guy.
I mean, the Beatles last
performance on the rooftop
of the Apple building.
Man, that would have been
cool, but I'm not that big
of a Beatles fan.
I was like, I'll probably have to go
with the Merle Haggard thing.
Okay, can I guess what you went with?
Yes, 'cause you're going to be wrong.
Well, I thought you were
gonna say when Johnny Cash
performed in San Quentin and
Merle Haggard was in the crowd.
Oh, that would be a good one.
So, then I'd be, oh, that would be cool.
I didn't even think of that.
That's a good one.
Or you'd be a level above Merle.
And I'd have to find Merle in there.
You could find him.
That'd be really cool.
I actually settled on
the recording session
for my favorite Merle song.
"I'm Always on a Mountain When I Fall"
is my favorite Merle song,
which incidentally, he did not write.
So, that kind of makes
me wanna change my mind.
You know, the album from 1978,
"I'm Always on a Mountain When
I Fall" also the title track,
which is my favorite, "It's
Been a Great Afternoon"
is the second track, which is
maybe my second Merle song.
Talking about having a hangover
and then having an afternoon
delight to get over it.
It's like, you can write this stuff
and it be on country radio in 1978.
So, I would travel back
to the year I was born
and instead of going to the
concert, I would go to the,
I would love to be hanging
out in the recording session
because I love those songs because,
those two songs in particular,
they represent my favorite
Merle songs because of the
production and the decisions
that are made, and you
know, the musicianship.
And, I mean, someone like
Britain, I interact with him
with music a lot, and
he's so into live music,
and he's connected with
that, but that's something
that we never really
did that much, you know?
I feel like we missed out on that,
the way that he talks about it.
But there is something
magical about being attached
to a song, a particular
performance of a song,
that was laid down and was,
let's say it was the most
like he wanted it to be.
So, it's like, every pluck of the string,
or every hit of the hand on the lap,
you know how on "It's
Been A Great Afternoon"
the drumbeat is just a guy
playing his lap with his hands?
It's just so creative.
You feel like you're in the room,
and I would love to be in the
room and see that's happening.
Because every time you listen
to the song, it's like,
I was there the one time
that they laid down this
track forever, you know?
I was in a bubble.
I was in a bubble, I was in
a safe bubble in the corner.
They didn't know I was there.
No, I would wanna talk to them.
Just hanging out.
I think in my old age
I just wanna hang out
in recording studios.
Maybe I'll be, like, a
recording studio janitor
slash sound engineer.
Recording studios are
going away though, man.
People are just doing
it in their bedrooms.
Yeah, that's another reason.
You'd be just a person
in someone's bedroom
which is weird.
So, I would go back to
1978, Merle's first album
when he left Capitol and he went to MCA.
He was kind of faltering a little bit.
He wanted to try something new.
He brought his band over and he had this--
Try some jazzy stuff.
Yeah, he had this renaissance.
The album after that was
"Serving 190 Proof", you know,
was one of his best albums.
That might be my favorite Merle album.
But this was the moment where it was like,
maybe in the studio you could sense
that there was a turning
point, because it was.
And I would know that.
It's like, this is exciting.
And it seems like, I don't
know how it would seem.
You know, maybe it would suck.
I'm sure it would be awesome,
but it would probably also
be somewhat underwhelming, right?
That opening acoustic ,
you know, like the beginning?
The way that--
Just watching that happen.
The way that songs come together.
Being committed to tape, yeah.
Oh, it was the seventh take.
It was the seventh take they used.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, but I would be there for that take.
That would be cool enough.
Yeah, but would it be cool enough
when you hear it six
times from your bubble?
That'd be better than in the
heat of the Egyptian desert
saying, "Oh yeah."
No, the bubble is air conditioned.
Oh it is?
Yes, you can be naked in the
bubble and no one can see,
you can't get hurt.
I wanna talk to people as
like a wandering stranger.
Well, that's a different thing.
Being able to inhabit a body--
I mean, if Jesus rose from the dead,
I would want to have a
conversation with him.
Well, yeah, you can talk from it.
They can hear you.
It would, kind of, be
disconcerting for Merle probably.
There's a naked man in a bubble,
it would change the trajectory of--
If you could have a conversation,
then that's a violation
of the rules because at that
point you could change it.
Because when I thought more
about this, I did think,
you know, practically speaking,
I would go back to however
coronavirus started, right?
Most likely somebody ate something, right?
That's the best theory at this point.
Thought we were gonna go the whole episode
without talking about coronavirus.
You already talked about masks.
Maybe it was engineered by somebody,
okay, maybe that happened.
But like, go back to the
moment where it was starting
and be like, "Oh no, no,
no, let's not eat that."
Or, "Let's not release
that into the world."
That's a different exercise.
Yeah, but you can't do
that, you can't go back.
Then there's lots of
things we'd wanna change.
Right.
And you know what?
Maybe that would be wrong
because maybe the world
is experiencing exactly what it's supposed
to be experiencing right now.
It's all part of it.
All part of the process.
Well, I'm glad we talked about this.
I was afraid I was gonna
look like an idiot.
Honestly, I was like,
"Man, I don't wanna answer
"this question 'cause I feel
like there's some really good
"answers and I'm just
gonna give stupid answers."
I think you gave good answers.
It doesn't matter.
They're my answers, and I
came to grips with that.
Right.
But thanks for trying to reassure me.
I'm not an idiot, but.
What are your answers?
Hashtag EarBiscuits.
Oh, but you've had a rec.
I got a rec.
Yeah.
Oh boy, do I have a rec?
Oh man, I was trying to
come up with a rec, and man,
I'm just like, "Man, I'm
gonna look like an idiot."
I'm frustrated.
I do feel like my world's
gotten so damn small.
Yeah.
That I'm like, my level of
enjoyment has gone down.
I gotta turn a corner.
I know I was a bit of a downer last week.
Yeah, this was a lot of fun,
having this conversation.
Good.
My recommendation, the best,
I discovered a new snack.
Now, the snacks that always blow us away,
and that are also healthy, are
these Blue Diamond Almonds.
Every time we have them on the show.
Not a sponsor though.
Not a sponsor, we're just gushing
about these bold-flavored almonds,
like the salt and vinegar,
and then the sriracha,
and you can buy a variety pack.
I don't know how we
got these in our house,
but I am recommending the
habanero barbecue almonds.
Oh, that sounds good.
Bold flavor.
If you're afraid of spicy-hot things,
you might not want to try these,
so that's why I'm making
this recommendation because--
Because they're not actually hot.
They're not actually
hot, and they're so good.
It's just crazy.
They're better than the sriracha?
Yeah, to me, they're definitely
better than sriracha,
and they're better than salt and vinegar.
They have a better flavor.
But it's nice to have the variety.
But that is my rec in effect this week,
is the Habanero barbecue
Blue Diamond Almonds.
Sometimes all you need is a good snack.
All you need, yeah,
just a handful of nuts.
Why don't we have them here?
As a healthy snack.
We got salt and vinegar here.
Because we got a crate
of salt and vinegar,
and what we should have gotten was a crate
of the variety pack which they sell.
Yeah, because I like the sriracha better
than the salt and vinegar,
and I guess I'm gonna
like habanero, what is it?
And I've gotten tired of those two,
that's why I'm so happy with the--
I'm not a huge fan of the
wasabi, a lot of people
like the wasabi, and I
like wasabi on my sushi,
but I do not like the wasabi nuts.
There you have it.
Hashtag EarBiscuits.
Let us know what your answer is.
If you could travel anywhere in the past.
It doesn't have to be three,
it doesn't have to be three.
Yeah, just do one.
It could just be one.
You'll be in a bubble, unclothed.
You'll be naked.
Temperature controlled.
You can wear shorts and
not be ashamed of it.
Yeah.
Let everyone see the rash on your thigh.
No one will see you, they can't see you
because then you could
alter, because then you could
just do, like, sign
language and alter history.
They can't see you.
It's an invisible bubble.
But you can get as close
as you want to anything.
You could even go back to the
moment of your own conception.
That would be horrible.
Yeah, that would be really weird.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuit
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.